thoughts on Rosie allegedly yelling at
Barbara Walters backstage for not
reaching out to her during the time
Trump was being mean to her that was bad
Jerry Shepard is spilling all the view
tees you can't get him Barbara Walters
phase sherry who co-hosted the popular
talk show from 2007 to 2014 appeared on
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
on Sunday and was asked a series of
rapid-fire questions about the view
tell-all book that was released in April
ladies who punch did you read it
no I didn't read it because I lived in
yeah right yesterday while sherry didn't
read the book she was happy to dive into
the juiciest revelations I'm not gonna
sit there and get reprimanded on the air
including the audio that was released of
Elisabeth Hasselbeck angrily threatening
to quit during a commercial break after
Barbara Walters reprimanded her on-air I
was there and I went Elizabeth was gonna
walk up I was like boy y'all white
people or something else you got the
guys Jerry who's still good friends with
Elizabeth also reacted to Rosie
O'Donnell saying she had a crush on
Elizabeth
well I mean you know if Rosie got a
crush on you the 52 year old also
weighed in on Jenny McCarthy's comments
about being miserable during her time on
the show and her not so great
relationship with Barbara I'm very
honest very raw very real yeah I got dr.
Foote doing them one time Ginny had an
outfit on and Barbara wanted the same
outfit she wanted to wear the same
outfit that Ginny had all right so that
was not a compliment when you nineteen
and is 80
Andy even recalls one time when he
co-hosted the daytime show and Barbara
was critical of him I remember once I
was co-hosting with you ladies something
new and Barbara handed my ass to did I
remember to head you and Jenny were so
nice to me you talked me off the ledge
I know et spoke to sherry in April where
she admitted that her time on the view
was hard at times everybody has their
own filter of when they were at the view
if some people had you
not so great experiences and some people
had really wonderful experiences so I
would just say from my end it was the
best experience of my life I cried for
three years straight because I had a
very tough taskmaster who I love her to
death is Barbara Walters but Barbara
Walters was tough on the people that she
loved and she helped me find my voice so
I will forever be indebted to Barbara
Walters well if we go over joy behar and
Elizabeth Hasselbeck and Jenny McCarthy
for the time that I had on the view
because what I have now is because of
the view
[Music]
[Applause]